What dosage of Tudka would you recommend for someone taking it to help the liver if they're taking
Ivermectin and penbenzo. So Tudka is a product that just actually came out just a few years ago and it is
It has been tested, the studies about Tudka has been shown that it's been tested to really help with liver detoxification.
It helps with phase 2 detoxification in the liver and it can be a good product to help with liver detoxification.
Would milk this will be better? Well, it depends. So I mean, we typically use the cheek swab to test for what product is going to be better.
First, to answer the question, what's the recommended dosage of Tudka? It depends on the product itself that you're taking.
If it's a cell core Tudka or body bio Tudka, we typically recommend one to two a day.
Is it going to help with getting rid of penbenzo and Ivermectin detoxified it so it doesn't damage the liver? Yes, it can.
Can milk this will be better? In some people, yes, so milk this will also help with phase 2 detoxification.
So does our product called phase 2, which is the pond 1 assist helps with the pond 1 pathway.
So are any of them contraindicative in hormone positive breast cancer or any breast cancer? No, they wouldn't be.
There is nothing negative about Tudka itself as far as contraindications for cancer patients.
There's nothing with milk whistle that would be a contraindicative for breast cancer or any cancer either, so you could use either.